hey guys what's up I'm Alana and welcome
to my channel and today I'm doing
another nonnamous Q&A for hitting 95,000
subscribers thank you guys so so much
for subscribing I'm trying my best to
put out like one video a week at the
moment it's very hard because I don't
have a lot of free time but I'm doing my
best I just want to say thank you guys
for watching so I didn't cut many
questions from this I cut stuff that
I've been asked before what do you guys
ask me about living in the u.s. a lot of
people ask stuff like my favorite game
which of course I have answered in
previous Q&A if you want to check those
out there are tons of them on my channel
from across the years at this point
there were also a whole bunch of
questions about but stuff because I've
never been asked questions about but
stuff before and this time got like 5 to
10 questions about but stuff I assumed
it was just look the same one person
asking all of these questions please
calm down
question number one are you trying to
keep your Australian accent or is it
just hard to shake it's pretty weird how
often people talk about this um people
like say that I'm putting on an American
accent or faking an Australian accent or
that I can't pick an accent some people
say my accent has changed a lot some
people say it hasn't at all the way I
feel about that is largely that my
accent hasn't changed very much maybe
every few words I don't think that my
aunn's will ever change like I say he'll
I don't think I'm ever going to say here
that see it's very hard for me to even
fake say that what do you think is a
good first date to take someone you met
at comic-con also how long after meeting
said person do you wait to ask them on a
date you guys actually ask me a lot of
dating questions uh which is insane
because I don't really date by that I
mean I'm pretty much dedicated to one
person or 100% single there's like no
dating period for me really at all so I
mean while I totally an interested in
dating culture I don't feel like I'm the
best person to answer this kind of stuff
so I'm just going to attempt to but take
it with a grain of salt for a good first
date to take someone on for me I like
active stuff a fun stuff I think that's
a cool date like laser tag or bowling or
driving range or you know something
where you can like make fun of each
other and loft-like also get to know
each other but in like a fun kind of
setting not something that's super
serious because
you know especially for two young people
dating should be fun and how long after
meeting someone you wait to ask them on
a date with the people I end up dating I
usually am the one to initiate the first
date and I don't wait a time period I
kind of wait until I feel like what
mutually interested in taking their
relationship further if you have to
either give up IGN and gaming or being a
DJ which one would it be uh definitely
being a DJ I basically already have
given up
I am DJing on the 30th of this month at
a gamer X in Santa Clara if you want to
come hang out and I will be DJing a
whole bunch when I go to pax oz in
Australia in November but in general
I've pretty much given up on DJing in
the u.s. because I don't know anyone
here being that I haven't looked at for
very long and obviously I don't work in
the music industry predominantly that
was always just like a hobby it's
basically impossible for me to get shows
here anyone that I've reached out to
even if I offered to DJ for free just as
a trial they just pretty much don't
respond ever so uh it's not really
walking out but I also just don't have a
lot of free time for it how many dicks
have you sucked tree fitty could you
talk about your routine slash diet also
how you take care of your hair um I got
tons of questions about my routine and
diet and answering that would take a
full length video so I'm just going to
make one of those for you guys so for
every single person who asked this
question stay tuned I will answer that
that the same applies to every person
who wants to how I go to job IGN I
intend to make a video exactly lining
out how I did that
so I will make one of those would you
ever want to guest on the RT podcast or
any other risky shows sure if it worked
out that way I'm pretty much always open
to that I've been on the go optional
podcast before which was like a very
different audience to my audience but
really really enjoyed being on that
podcast which is um for those who don't
know total this gets podcast I feel like
that was a couple years ago now but it
was really cool um generally like any of
that kind of stuff that people ask me to
do I will say yes to because I think
collaborating with other outlets like
that especially with people that I don't
know that well is always really really
fun would you date a 40-something guy
being the I and
just 123 a few weeks ago I probably
wouldn't date a 40-something guy I did
date a guy who is eight years older than
me once and like on paper that sounded
very strange but it wasn't I would
consider myself to be a fairly mature
person and he was not very mature so
it's like we kind of just met in the
middle
so having that experience kind of made
me think that people really overweight
age differences sometimes I feel like
someone who has double my age is
probably a bit much what is your natural
hair color hopefully not gray um I don't
really know see see that pot and then
how there's an orangey line the pot
before the orangey line is my natural
hair color so it's like blonde dish
would you ever do professional photo
shoots
whether it be nude I mean I guess I've
sort of half kind of done professional
photo shoots like not in it I paid for
them but I've worked with photographers
who were professional enough that was
literally that profession and have done
that kind of stuff but mostly relating
to cosplay but I mean no I would
literally never do a nude photo shoot I
mean okay I don't want to say never
because maybe I could change
dramatically as a personal you know
maybe if it was something like breast
cancer I would consider doing something
like that
if it will like sense it but in general
I really don't like having my picture
taken if it's like someone in the
picture with me it's totally fine but
generally if someone else to take a
photo of me I just feel very
uncomfortable what is your favorite type
of eggs
I eat so many boiled egg whites I think
I probably have like ten eggs a week
just as boiled egg whites I eat that
[ __ ] up who is your hero um my mum and
call sagen are you dating someone right
now usually I skip this question but I
got it so much that I'm just gonna say I
currently am seeing someone yes have you
read any good books lately I'm in love
with new 52 Batman if you will count
that like everyone should read quoted
yells and death of the family those are
both freaking awesome but I am currently
reading The Wheel of Time series I'm on
book three about halfway through that
right
I'm really really enjoying the series so
for those who don't know it's a it's a
fantasy series I think this 15 or 16
books in total and everyone says it gets
kind of boring around books 4 and 5 I
think but I'm gonna try to get through
it uh it's gonna take me probably a
decade to finish the series though
favorite topping on pizza I recognize
that this is a weird choice but anytime
I can get some kind of spinach and feta
combo on a pizza I'm down how often do
you get asked out I really wanted to
answer this one because the the answer
is like not very often people ask me out
on the internet a fair amount but it
almost never happens in person I think
people have it in the heads that it's
like so easy for women and get us down
on dates and it happens all the time and
like that is straight up not true there
is a difference between being hit on and
asked out though those are two totally
separate things that is it for me to
everyone thank you so much for you guys
who asked questions again sorry but in
answer it's because I'm in hospital or I
didn't have an interesting answer and my
next Q&A I guess in theory would be a
non anonymous one when I hit a hundred
thousand subscribers which is a thing
that may actually happen which is crazy
but also people have been asking if I
have any cool like a hundred thousand
subscribers plans and I have no idea
what to do but I would love to do
something cool for it so let me know if
you have any ideas I'd love to hear them
and may get something out and also this
is the thing that I totally forgot that
I set up there is a support my channel
option where you can donate to my
channel if you want to I've never like
promoted that kind of stuff because I'm
always super weird about asking for
money um but I did want to give a shout
out to Nick Adam Lippmann you are the
first person to support my channel thank
you so much I totally forgot that that
was a thing that even existed on YouTube
and that is just the coolest thing I
like what an awesome surprise thank you
so much that is [ __ ] rat and that is
it for me today you guys will hopefully
have another video up next week and I
guess I will see you all then bye